melanie newman alongside yonder alonso
and buck showalter
2-2 chapman swings he tees this one off
to deep center field adolescarcia leaps
at the wall take a long look at that one
matt chapman gets it started with a
two-run blast
just an absolute gorgeous at-bat right
there he was able to put a good swing on
a fast but more down in the zone
to take that ball straight
that away center and that that's not a
small park yeah and he's not ever able
to establish anything off speed and
everything's been fastball and we all
know what major league hitters will do
with that and that's going to be the
line for taylor hearn this evening
manager chris woodward is out and
that'll be about it brent de gus is in
and take a look here his 19th appearance
on the season just 23 years old he just
felt like they have to make an
adjustment on that
base it elvis andrews his first since
returning back to texas
and the a's keep piling it on
just a beautiful swing for elvis anders
right there
his first hit and it's a two-run single
he's tallying them up four nothing here
in the first and still trying to find
that final out
and ramon it's a fly wall to deep right
center garcia back at the track he will
watch it fly and loriano blasts a
two-run home run out to right center all
of a sudden the ease leads seven nothing
in the second
right center field shot
by lauriano his 13th home run
somebody's going to be told
you've got to give us some innings
yep because
the way this is going
very happy for the athletics
yeah everybody wants to talk about the
run differential well
this is a good start for the a's
athletics up seven nothing after two
innings
jordan lyles is trying to come on in
relief here and has not found the answer
yet
rbi single for mark canna and the a's
are just pouring it on right now there's
excuse me two runs come home on that
it's nine nothing oakland in the third
and texas is just trying to make north
from south right now
well it's a rip for willie calhoun and
the rangers may actually finally be
getting on the board here
as coming around to score and look at
this texas with an answer
nick solak reached on the hit by pitch
willie calhoun from the left side with
an rbi double
they break on the board it's a 9-1 ball
game here in the fifth inning and the
first that cole irvine has given up
today
if you're the hitter and you get that
double you want that guy the same way
you would want to run and i love scoring
because i would always scream my score
for my friends i always score for my
friends that's the bottom goal is to
score runs well and they are playing the
corners in this one here charlie
culberson up the right side this time
and the rangers have two in the inning
willie calhoun comes home it's a charlie
culberson double
two extra bases given up by cole irvin
here in the fifth cole irvine's trying
to put this one away he's got two outs
but a runner at third something you're
kind of hearing more in the game is just
the overall athlete as he takes a hat
this one drops in for a base hit it
evades kenneth colberson walks home and
he'll hold up at second base three
doubles in the inning eli white finds it
here he's gone back to back now in plate
appearances
9-3 a still with a pretty big lead
swing here and it is a hit parade off of
irvin here in the fifth inning
here comes eli white and the rangers are
finding their groove here against cole
irvin odolis garcia his first hit of the
ball game it goes for an rbi it's 9-4
[Applause]
swing here and a big one for eli white
heading back out and don't even try to
get this one
it's an upper deck shot eli white with a
massive blast
touch em all they're within four nine to
five
three hit performance for white today
and he keeps elevating one after the
next well he's turning 27 on saturday
but my goodness this is a pre-gift to
his birthday celebration an absolute
bomb
440
feet and you know that's a new park so
you know there aren't a lot of names on
the upper deck list yet you know we're
facing that guy like like deepman right
here who who likes to throw his fastball
now he loves to pound the zone with
fastballs but any chance you you have to
put away a powerful hitter like gallow
we're looking to that slider gallow gets
a hold of a fastball up and get out ball
gallow attacks jake diekmann
ranger on former ranger here and it's
9-6 texas is threatening here in the
eighth
his eighth
of 13
against lefties
without a doubt
big hit right there big hit
jed lowry with a difference maker here
as he drives one into left field and the
a's pushing double digits
an rbi single and it's 10-6 oakland what
a great piece of hitting there not
trying to do too much you want to stay
out of the middle of the infield there
because the double plays in play they
pinched him completely up the middle you
can tell by his lead that he's going on
contact down contact
2-1 pitch swing and that's another deep
down to left field
oakland has found life after they went
quiet for the last five innings and
they're pouring it on to texas now 12-6
and a base is clearing double for sean
murphy and we get that pitch up in the
zone right just exactly what the doctor
ordered and
he was able to just connect not trying
to do too much
and they're still driving off of
demarcus evans here sky bolt drops a
base hit out into right field
and coming on now 13-6
oakland bolt arrives safely at second
base and it is not demarcus evans night
here so far his 32nd pitch of the inning
after texas had battled to come within
three the a's have now doubled what the
rangers have been able to put on the
board there's two down
for dale asgara the a's with a big 13-6
lead after their onslaught in the ninth
but a man with a home run on the evening
eli white he swings and it's a squib
right back matt chapman he recovers the
throw is in time that's going to be
the ball game here for the a's they take
it 13-6